on va écouter le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson qui est en
train de s'exprimer en ce moment on en
reparle juste après
et man 2
le potentiel de souhaits
se séparer de la russie et je peux
confirmer comme je lé bris
que toutes les options sont sur la table
toutefois pour que ces mesures soient a
couronné de succès il est essentiel que
nous soyons unis
avec nos partenaires du g7 et d'autres
organisations
monsieur le président
les investisseurs
donnent déjà leur verdict sur l'action
de cooking et les
la bourse russe a déjà chuté
250 milliards de dollars 2 perdu un seul
jour c'est un
robin comme le plus grand prêteur a
chuté de
45% et 15 pence en baisse de 39% le
rouble quant à lui a également chuté il
s'est effondré contre le dollar nous
allons continuer notre mission pour
exercer une plus grande pression sur la
russie tu pourras l'exclure de l'edge du
pied internationale mais nous
utiliserons évidemment la position du
royaume uni dans toutes les
organisations pour condamner pour
condamner cette invasion de l'udc l'un
et nous allons contrer le blizzard une
du kremlin le mensonge en racontant la
vérité sur la guerre de choix de poutine
et sa guerre d'agression ils
travailleront de concert avec nos alliés
afin de protéger les autres pays
européens qui ne sont pas membres de
l'otan et qui pourraient devenir des
cibles 2e poutine et de son agression
nous résisterons
nous résisterons à toute tentation
subversive d'accepter ce que poutine
fait aujourd'hui comme a fait accompli
il n'y aura pas de normalisation pas
aujourd'hui pas dans un mois bah dans
les années à venir nous devons renforcer
les défenses de l'otan étaient davantage
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé une réunion des
dirigeants de l'otan qui aura lieu
demain et je réunirai les pays qui
contribuent au fort cette expédition
conjointe menée par le royaume uni et
qui comprennent des forces de l'otan et
des membres et des fondements de nos
membres de l'otan
samedi dernier j'avais averti que cette
invasion aurait des conséquences
économiques mondiales ce matin le prix
du pétrole a énormément augmenté le
gouvernement fera tout son pouvoir pour
protéger nos concitoyens des
répercussions sur l'or le coût de la vie
est bien évidemment nous sommes prêt
prêt à protéger notre pays contre toutes
les menaces y compris sur le dans le
cyberespace
mais surtout
la chambre a conscience de la
vérité que nous vivons dans un continent
où un pouvoir expansionniste a déployé
la plus grande armée et cherche à
redessiner elle les frontières de
l'europe dans le sens et guérir à un
état indépendant par la force des armes
il était essentiel pour la sécurité de
toutes les nations que
cet exercice de poutine un échec comme
il est voué à l'aise
peu importe le temps que cela prendra ce
sera l'objectif ferme et non bâti enduro
émis tous les membres de cette doute
celui de tous les membres du parlement
et ensemble nous avons le pouvoir et la
volonté de défendre la paix et la
justice comme nous l'avons toujours fait
et je déclare au peuple russe dont le
président vient d'autoriser une attaque
contre ana et a slave frère je n'en
reviens pas que cette horreur se
produisent en votre nom ou que vous
souhaitez réellement le statut de paria
que ces actions vous donneront
à nos amis ukrainiens
en ce moments d'agonie je vous dis que
nous sommes à vos côtés nous sommes de
votre côté votre droit de choisir votre
d'état est un droit que le royaume uni
et que nos alliés protégeront toujours
et dans cet esprit je vous dis cela va
mieux craignent à et je te présente
favorablement cette déclaration à la
chambre le membre de l'opposition car
starmer
merci monsieur le président en ces temps
difficiles nos pensées notre solidarité
et notre détermination sont avec le
peuple ukrainien
des soldats ont envahi voruz des
missiles ont frappé vauville
vous avez été plongé dans une guerre
mais sans
que ce soit votre faute parce que
poutine avait peur de votre liberté
parce qu'il lit ces
personnes ne choisira de vie voilà vous
avez pu
voir en direct sur notre antenne
boris johnson s'exprimer devant les
députés britanniques